en bas 13455 pour le bain et 200 donc
longtemps il y a
un pétrolier jaune près du champ
oh
celui à gaz désolé je l'ai enlevé pour pouvoir prendre une
photo en regardant le G
ouais tant pis pour
moi Hôtel X vent 1 190 à
retour
pas
radio bonne  matin
c'est B 2011 radio
matin bon matin B 20
demande 15000 direct
Pang B 2011 Roger demandes d'autorisation
préférées Piste 1 7 vent 1 90 12 Tim 2
niner niner 5
ceci
[Musique]
ok c'est quoi la
rue principale Main Street  ici,
le but est de montrer que c'est une très
grande c'est une grande ville ouais et
la grande ville, d'accord, où les maisons vont
bientôt arriver, peut-être que je devrais commencer par le logement
des maisons et puis oui, et puis au fur et à mesure que nous
parcourons la  maisons nous viendrons nous
verrons le reste de la ville en
arrière-plan ouais tu sors
la radio d'abord, tiens-toi premier 860 Rog
merci
oh on peut voir la maison de Matthew à
gauche nous avons commencé la maison de Matthew ouais
ouais la bleue à gauche continue
continuez comme
ça, continuez à venir et nous verrons
la ville en arrière-plan et puis
probablement beaucoup de monde
ici, un peu d'océan en arrière-
plan, nous mettons un peu de hauteur
pour voir que la ville euh bien sûr
sans disparaître  un peu derrière la
colline
là-bas,
puis un peu comme quelques euh
petits plans de euh feux de voitures, ok, les
maisons individuelles,
oui, doivent être différentes des autres
villages que nous avons déjà faits, ok,
donc vous voulez que les maisons, les voitures laissent tomber la voiture S
ici ouais, comme beaucoup de lumières de feu
et c'est
bien plus rapide que les
villages Super
marché c'est des bâtiments dans cette photo
ouais c'est une bonne
photo comme zoomer sur ces voitures la circulation
est pleine Z oh c'est pleine Z ouais
ok ce que je suis  pensant que je sors en
grand angle et que ces maisons ici à
droite à
gauche, ok, pourquoi ne pas partir d'
une maison et faire un zoom arrière
depuis les maisons ouais, euh, certaines maisons ici
peut-être
Hé, où est le bâtiment avec une droite
là, oh la  sinon là ce grand
bâtiment ceux-là là tu veux ces
bâtiments non non le rond le
parlement le bâtiment du Parlement ok celui
du
ouais genre de zoom arrière de la
ville ok
ouais ok on a fini ouais ok
[Musique]
oui j'ai
fini ok  nous allons voyager, nous partirons
maintenant, il
fera
chaud,
ok, nous arrêtons d'enregistrer